françaises français
mes meilleurs voeux de nouvelle année
je vous les offre de tout mon coeur
un coeur que depuis longtemps
permettez-moi de le dire
n'épargne pas les soucis au sujet du
sort de la france
mais qui je voue la firme est
aujourd'hui remplie d'espoir
certes au printemps dernier notre pays
qui depuis dix ans
gravit la pente du renouveau
s'est trouvé dans son ascension tout à
coup saisi de vertige
on a même pu croire un moment qui
s'abandonnait à la très morbide de la
bim et qu'il allait rouler jusqu'au plus
bas
par la suite le grave déséquilibre de
notre économie
résultat inéluctable
d'une paralysie de près de deux mois
des charges énormes subitement consentis
pour la faire cesser
et des crédits
massivement prodigués pour la reprise
nous a conduits soudain et à chaud
à une crise monétaire
qui mettait en cause la valeur de notre
franc et par là même celle de nos avoirs
et de nos rémunérations
risquait de nous faire passer sous la
dépendance de prêteurs étrangers
et suscitait la joie odieuse
des spéculateurs
de la finance de la politique et de la
presse qui jouait notre déconfiture
mais au bout du compte que nous est-il
arrivé
ceux-ci d'abord
qu'après son passage à vide la nation
française
r- saisi
le 30 mai
est là d'un seul coup
montrer
massivement qu'elles répondaient à
l'appel du chef de l'état
après quoi par les élections
elle approuve et d'une manière éclatante
sa volonté de voir assurer l'ordre
maintenir les institutions et poursuivre
la marche vers le progrès
ceci encore nous est arrivé
coût total est dans l'ensemble
le bon sens reprend ses droits à
l'intérieur de nos facultés
il nous est arrivé ceci enfin
que notre activité productrice
vigoureusement relancer dépasse le taux
le plus élevé
qu'elle est encore jamais atteint
que notre monnaie ayant traversé
l'ouragan sans perdre sa parité
se tient ferme sur sa position
est que tous ceux qui
ont misé sur leur recul de la france en
sont pour leur honte et pour leurs frais
portons donc en terre
les diables qui nous ont tourmenté
pendant l'année qui se termine
laissons à leur complice et à leurs
partisans la tristesse et la déception
car le fait que nous ayons une fois de
plus
heureusement surmonter les épreuves
nous donne les meilleures raisons d'être
confiants en nous mêmes
cependant il est bien vrai que nous ne
réparons pas dans la pagaille
et dans la facilité et mauvais coups qui
viennent d'être portées à notre pays
pour l'éducation nationale
leur retour à l'anarchie ne doit pas
être toléré
sous peine que soit inapplicable tout ce
qui a été fait pour elle depuis dix ans
et tout ce qui est en voie de l'être
grâce à la loi d'orientation
l'intérêt public exige
qu indépendamment des mesures qu'il a
comme ailleurs un compte aux services
d'ordre
ils reviennent à ceux qui dans nos
universités nos lycées nos écoles sont
en fonction c'est à dire en charge et en
responsabilité
d'y exercer leur autorité
et aux enseignants aux étudiants aux
familles de les y aider activement
pour l'économie qu'il s'agisse des prix
et des salaires
ou bien les dépenses publiques
ou bien des changes et du crédit
les limitations les contrôles voulu sont
absolument nécessaires
jusqu'au retour complet à l'équilibré
ceci
pour que nous puissions sauvegarder la
balance de nos paiements
consolider dans la réalité
les accroissements de rémunération qui
ont été apparemment fixé dans les
chiffres
faire en sorte que nous vendions au
dehors au moins autant que nous y
achetons
bref
empêcher
que la supercherie de l'inflation
ne nous fasse glisser
au gouffre de la ruine et la misère
comme jadis le chant des sirènes faisait
tomber les marins dans la mer
alors
nous étant remis d'aplomb
nous franchirons certainement
dans l'expansion et dans la règle
une étape nouvelle de développement et
de prospérité
encore faut-il que nous surmontions le
malaise moral
qui chez nous plus que partout à cause
d'autres individus à l'isthme
est inhérent à la civilisation mécanique
et matérialiste moderne
faute de quoi les fanatiques de la
destruction les doctrinaires de la
négation
et les spécialistes
de la démagogie
aurait encore une fois beau jeu
de susciter amertume
pour provoqué l'agitation
sans que d'ailleurs leur stérilité
qu'ils appellent insolemment
et dérisoirement la révolution
puis se tendre à rien d'autre qu'à tout
dissoudre dans le néant ou bien tous
poussés sous les broyeuses totalitaire
or à l'origine de ce trouble
il y a le sentiment attristant irritant
qu'éprouvent les hommes d'à présent être
saisie est entraînée par un engrenage
économique et social sur lequel ils
n'ont pas de prise et qui fait d'eux des
instruments
à ce mal du siècle
qui est le mal des âmes
nous pouvons pour notre part
contribuer à remédier
en organisant la participation de tous à
la marche de l'activité
à laquelle il contribue
de telle façon que chacun soit dignement
associés
à ce qui se passe à son propre sujet et
qu'il assume des devoirs en même temps
qu'il fait valoir des droits c'est cela
que nous sommes en train de faire dans
notre université
c'est cela que nous allons développer
après l'avoir commencé à l'intérieur de
nos entreprises
c'est cela que nous réaliserons en
associant les collectivités
territoriales de notre pays
et les catégories économiques et
sociales
soit au plan de la région aux mesures
qui touchent la vie locale
soit au plan de la nation à la
préparation des lois voilà la réforme de
la condition des hommes autrement dit de
leur rapport
qui doit marquer l'an de grâce
et nous faire à la fois plus fort et
plus fraternel
d'autant mieux que si nous français
ne sommes pas actuellement une nation
physiquement gigantesque
si par exemple il nous faut
laisser à d'autres
l'admirable mérite de réussir le tour de
la lune
nous n'avons pas moins à jouer dans le
monde al avantage de tous les peuples un
rôle qu'ils soient bien à nous
cela implique
que sans nuire aucunement à nos amitiés
traditionnels
nous restions solide et
indépendant
c'est parce que nous le sommes redevenus
depuis dix ans après une longue période
où le malheur
alternaient avec l'inconsistance
que nous nous trouvons en mesure d'agir
pour aider efficacement
à la solution des problèmes aigus de
l'univers
lesquels
chacun peut les énumérer
il s'agit de la détente et de la
coopération a pratiqué au lieu de la
guerre froide avec le reste de l'europe
qui d'ailleurs de ce fait est en
évolution
soit aussi
du l'affreux conflit vietnamien
auxquels peuvent mettre un terme des
négociations à paris
soit de l'issue internationale
au drame du moyen-orient
issue qui est déjà tracée
mais qui doit être absolument mise en
oeuvre ceux dont les grandes puissances
ont les moyens
par l'évacuation
des territoires conquis par la force
la garantie accordée à chaque camp
quant à une juste frontières et quant à
sa sécurité
par
la libre navigation attribué par tous et
à tous
et par un sort acceptable
assurer aux réfugiés
il s'agit aussi de l'entrée de l'énorme
chine dans le concert des grandes
puissances et d'ensuite les nations
unies parce que
elle a sa place à y tenir et que l'
isolement ne vaut rien
soit encore
de la libre conduite de sa propre vie
nationale par le peuple français du
canada
soit du droit de disposer de lui même à
reconnaître aux vaillants bien fera
soit de l'aide qui doit être apportée
par les nations bien pourvus au progrès
de celles qui ne le sont pas
soit de l'établissement d'un système
monétaire mondial qui soit fondée non
pas sur le privilège d'une monnaie
mais sur deux critères impartiaux
d'une part la valeur de l'or
d'autre part une organisation du crédit
exclusive de la spéculation
ces positions qui sont les nôtres
qui ont été naguère apprenant contesté
mais que les événements justifie à
l'évidence
nous avons à les soutenir pour l'
équilibre et pour la paix du monde
car cette action là
elle est de notre intérêt vital
et elle répond parfaitement bien à la
nature et à la figure
millénaire de la patrie
française français
au début de l'année
pour la réussite de la france
je nous souhaite à tous
en son nom
la foi et l'espérance nationale
vive la république vive la france
[Musique]